so um i don't know how bad it'll get for
us in the united states but let's take a
look at what our leaders are telling us
in the story from daily mail democratic
senator debbie stabenow brags that it
doesn't matter to her how high gas
prices are because she drives by every
station in her electric vehicle let them
eat cake let them drive tesla okay so if
the meme of the person drowning getting
a high five from the person on the boat
were a person i was like holy cow i
cannot imagine a better employment
that's insane remember when colbert said
the same thing yeah he's like i don't
care if it's 20 bucks a gallon i just
haven't elected i said the same thing so
so i was uh i was on facebook and i see
these memes because i have like
thousands of people following me and
someone posted uh
gas prices are not joe biden's fault or
like you know something like that and
then i responded with
you know being snarky
if you can't afford an electric car you
can't afford to drive
you we are and i was like we are all in
this together with the environment and
and you drive around with carbon
emissions everywhere carrying nothing
for this world and then the lady who
posted it she was like i can't afford an
electric car and i said oh it's only
fifty thousand dollars and she's like i
can't afford i mean then then what do
you think is gonna happen when you drive
up gas prices or celebrate it yeah i
mean this was the lesson of covid was
the have the war between the haves and
the have-nots you were essential and you
could go to work or you were
non-essential and you couldn't go to
work i mean this was in in every way
what they chose to shut down and what
they chose to keep going
um the best part is that plum like
plumbers and labor and stuff was like
some of it was essential but all of the
journalists were essential it was like
okay that's okay everyone else go home
but if you're a blue check washington
post reporter you're good yeah you think
that uh you guys ever follow salt water
as a fuel you looked into that at all no
some people are burning salt there's got
john kansas we pulled this up in the
after show maybe he was uh running
microwaves through salt water looking
for a cure for cancer
one frequency lit it on fire salt water
just just a frequency and then you know
i haven't heard a lot about it for 12
years but maybe maybe because it's
nonsense there's a video on youtube of
him doing it and the other scientists
are like we should talk about it on the
after show but i mean there's a video on
point there's a video on youtube about
how the earth is flattening come on i'm
not saying the earth's not flat you're
saying it's not well well i'm saying if
it's true that saltwater has a lot of i
mean a lot of potential energy in it if
we really could burn the stuff why is it
like a cabal that's intentionally is
this just like a wealth transfer they're
going to charge as much as they can for
oil well until people can't pay any more
let's entertain
the the idea that you can burn salt
water i don't know if that's true or not
i'm not i'm not you know this buy
someone in the chat like like
the right word but um like you know
release heat from really yeah the issue
is that well you know i did some uh
reporting on the desalination plants in
california
it's actually really bad we cannot just
pull water from the ocean it creates
brine which then sinks to the bottom and
causes serious problems so the idea that
we can extract from the oceans is not a
long-term solution to anything so even
if we could take salt water and use it
for some kind of fuel you're going to
have byproducts you're going to have
waste products so that doesn't seem like
a solution geez i mean oil is giving us
enough of a product byproduct problem as
we go well look at batteries you know
these electric cars you know they're not
made out of some fairy winged al gore
coming up and and pooping them out of
his you know
another reason
they they come
really
these electric batteries don't come out
of nowhere they're not you know they're
not magic they don't just
they don't aren't just made out of
environmentally friendly you can't get
them exactly and there's a limit in
getting them and there's a shortage in
getting them and when you do get them it
is extremely destructive to the
environment there's a huge entire long
process and a lot of of even the solar
panel stuff a lot of it is just bigger
scams and when you look at the the
carbon footprint of of getting uh you
know they say you get it from sand no
you don't the way of getting it is it's
it's so complicated it has such an
effect on on the environment it really
makes you question this entire larger
scheme as like as a ponzi scheme it's
all about us yeah recycling also another
scam that a lot of people don't like to
talk about a lot of the recycled
material literally was shipped over to
china china just dumped it into the
ocean and now we have whole islands
filled with plastic so
there are legitimate issues that we
could talk about when it comes to the
destruction of our environment we don't
talk about that there's elaborative
ponzi schemes that literally transfer
the wealth from poor people to rich
people all in the name of fighting the
environment literally giving the money
to the people destroying the environment
which is which is bonkers i was in
chicago like this is like 15 years ago
and they had these big city
garbage bins and there's one hole that
says recycle and one hole it says
garbage and it goes to the same place
and they both go to the same shoot that
was like i looked at it i'm like wait a
minute it just goes on to slide into one
garbage can but i still i know this
intellectually and yet i still cannot
not do it it's like been ingrained from
childhood where you have to separate the
cardboard and the plastic and the
garbage and i can't not if it's got food
material on it you can't recycle it
anyway i know it's all nonsense and yet
i have this like ocd that i cannot not
do it i was in i was flying through
through uh i think i was in dallas and i
ordered an arnold palmer or something
lady comes and she brings it to me and
i'm in texas and she gives me a paper
straw and then i laughed and i was like
paper straws huh and then she goes some
dumb little girl complains about
plastic and also we can't have straws
anymore and i started laughing i was
like you get it yeah you know exactly
what's up shout out to boyan slat in the
ocean cleanup project have you guys been
following his work i interviewed him uh
when he went to bilderberg he actually
gave me an interesting comment about his
take there but he's also a fascinating
extremely young person that uh has been
doing some really fascinating work when
it comes to cleaning up the mess from
essentially the chinese uh dumping all
the trash into india into the ocean and
river when all the developing countries
the pacific gyre that giant texas-sized
swirling patch of plastic he's out there
with these giant ropes cleaning it up
but where does it go when he cleans he
brings it back to shore and then they
got to figure out what to do with the
plastic you can break it back down into
oil if you heat it up with low oxygen or
no oxygen environment you can reconvert
it there's a there's bacteria that
started eating it yeah there's bacteria
there's also mushrooms pestilopsis
microspore is a fungus that can consume
it turned into sugar
you've got to prevent sugar yeah you
grind it up into little plastic pellets
and then you run it through an aqueous
solution and spray it with the fungus
with the spores and then over like a
week it breaks it down into sugar that's
cool let me let me read a little bit
from this article this is funny the
average cost of an electric vehicle is
56
437 dollars which is approximately 100
10 000 higher than the industry average
so these i'm just i'm really hoping that
whatever ends up happening in november
we never forget they'll let them drive
tesla's line and it becomes like a thing
like let them drive teslas you know
these people are just like they're
complaining about gas prices why don't
they just drive teslas yeah i think
judge said it he's like people should
buy electric cars they're like
there's not enough of them there's no
batteries there's no cars that's why the
demand of them is going up yeah i i just
placed an order for a ford transit that
will arrive maybe at the end of the year
we're hoping tesla's back ordered
incredibly long prediction
um i think joe biden will likely invoke
the defense production act and some kind
of the democrats will introduce some
kind of bill magic massively fund
electric vehicle production in this
country and
not like cars uh big rigs that would
help you on muscle i thought you said
china wrong tim uh you said china
because biden's probably going to be
giving all the business to china
probably more than anywhere else that's
where he's buying the solar panels that
he's importing i'm saying when the
diesel shortage is hit in august you
think gas prices are a problem
you look if the truckers are going to be
spending 10 bucks a gallon on diesel
yeah a lot of them are going to be i'm
not driving anymore yeah then your
products are going to skyrocket so i
think joe biden's going to step in and
be like we got a problem with prices and
shortages man come on we gotta have to
do the defense production
it's gonna be like fruits and vegetables
that are gonna fly off the shelves and
that will be completely scarce
yeah it took him a really long time to
actually admit that there was a baby
formula shortage and he didn't really do
anything about it so i wonder if he's
actually going to do anything about that
all you guys think you're going to have
strawberries come october
people people no more strawberry ice
cream no
the things that need to be shipped and
shipped quickly not going to happen yeah
that's right yeah so you know whenever i
go to the store you know what really
bugs me is strawberries you got to like
check them you got to open it up and
make sure there's no mold in there and
then sometimes you do after a couple
days they're all moldy yeah and that
that's because they have to be
transported very quickly but if you buy
the strawberries that last more than
three days they're tasteless they're
gross yeah so there's no middle ground
or frozen strawberries really strong
feelings about strawberries
avocados gone so
12.92 cents at costco for a six-pack
whoa two bucks an avocado yeah that's
the millennial apocalypse
avocado toast i know i just saw it on
instacart and i was like oh that's not
going to happen have you been tracking
prices yes so so
we went to a mexican restaurant it's it
was it was i think me and three other
people
and the bill was 100 bucks that's low i
mean i keep kosher so i think that's low
but yes but but it's like
it's not like a year ago it was like 60
bucks really yeah i mean if we got a
couple tacos it would be like you know
10 bucks a person we're looking at 40
bucks with drinks i get takeout for my
family of seven and i have small
children it's nowhere under 150. wow you
can't do it we don't what area are you
in if you don't mind silver spring
maryland here yeah yeah i mean also i
keep kosher so you have to like put a 30
tax on life but i mean
do i
cheap tax prices
the local chinese place the just the
dinner special went up over 35 it is now
19 to get just a dinner
of chinese food yeah wasn't it like ten
bucks a year ago or something like that
no i mean his prices went up i mean and
i'm not blaming him obvi i'm not blaming
you but like it's just it's crazy yeah
and it's only the beginning it's only
going to get worse this is the inflation
is the largest tax on the people of the
world and and
your wealth is literally being
evaporated because of the financial
policies of the u.s federal reserve and
the biden administration
i'll tell you what was really scary for
me we went we have we have our truck for
transporting materials and stuff and for
removing the trailers and the mobile
studio we had to get an oil change
we were told we can't do it we don't
have any oil what we went to an oil
change place and they told us they
didn't have it and they couldn't help us
and then i was like what and they're
like you're gonna have a special truck
it's a dodge ram it's diesel yeah but
they were just like we don't have the
the oil you have to get you i'm sorry we
don't have it what does everyone else do
i mean like it's not like we live in
like manhattan we had to drive and i re
we're in the middle of nowhere we're out
here you know west virginia yeah we had
to drive to a couple stores to find
the right uh
oil we went to i think we went to like
an auto zone or something and then we
were like i i forgot the oil that we
need i'm sure everybody knows exactly
what we need and they had i think like
four uh uh
gallons or whatever and we needed i
think three two or three maybe maybe two
or something and so i was like just get
it all because they told us that there
was a shortage and they couldn't help us
they could they didn't have any and i'm
like wow that was that's never happened
to me in my life yeah in my life every
vehicle i've ever had my friends
vehicles they pulling like yep i mean
that's what i did with baby i i nurse my
b like he's never had formula and when
all of this stuff started i bought a
canister because i was like if i get hit
by a truck yeah i want i want that on
your hand one thing people are
mentioning the super chat's uh def
shortages what is df so i think it
wasn't i think 10 years ago there was a
uh the u.s passed a bill requiring all
new diesel maybe as long as this but all
new diesel vehicles need to have diesel
exhaust fluid which is basically urea
and water
and you so when you when we're filling
up the ram with gas there's actually two
holes a small one and a big one if you
go to a truck stop you can pull out the
def and stick it in and it smells like
piss because that's what it is it's like
this yeah but we import it
and so there's already shortages
if the truck doesn't have it it it gives
you a warning and says speed will be
reduced to five miles an hour
that is dystopian is it aware of their
global warming what yes
what def does is it bonds with the fuel
so that instead of making a pollutant or
whatever it makes water or something or
something like that it's like a nitrogen
something i think a lot of people egr
deleted their uh diesel trucks and they
don't have to do that and i think
there's some local state jurisdictions
that made that illegal but it's it's
kind of hard but sometimes people are
going to start hacking their vehicles oh
yeah they're going to try and find ways
to reduce the cost in whatever whatever
way they can
yeah i mean i looked into i mean at the
end of the day i don't know how much you
could hack
seven dollars a gallon
right biodiesel make your diesel from
corn i don't know
people are gonna be driving that but
that's not that's not that's not
effective i'm surprised that the
government
is not having more of a dialogue about
getting people to become
self-sustainable it still seems like
they're like hey wait for us to fix
things for you wait for us wait for us
right i mean they're saying you know
drive a tesla but you have to spend
fifty five thousand dollars minimum
because those are the the regular prices
that you could pre-order i know people
that are making money just off
pre-ordering tesla's because of the
value of how much they've been rapidly
increasing so they order one that's that
they're going to get in a year or two
years and then of course their value of
it skyrockets up and the ba the value of
the battery goes up so they sell it as
soon as they buy it and they make a
profit off of it and when you pre-order
you don't even put down the money right
you put down like 100 i think now they
want 200
uh whatever it may be five hundred
dollars i mean i don't know i've put
down a deposit on a ford transit this
week so yeah well an expert on it thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there
you